my lord you were here last week to show
us Dark Souls I was and I could only
show stuff from the first hour of the
game it was great we got to ask you
super vague questions that you could not
sponsor yeah totally I can now hopefully
respond to more although I want to be
careful I want to be too spoilery okay
but I do want to give this morning Dark
Souls is all about discovery right and
so you are gonna be seeing something
that's later in the game I chose
something specifically that's rather
Dark Souls II okay doesn't come across
as like - oh my god I can't believe I'm
seeing that so what it's worth if you
you know if you're kind of sensitive
about [ __ ] so pushing my way man stay
yes and watch video games talk so as to
what's going on here so this is hanging
out live fire outside yeah this is a
bonfire concerning all right all these
keeed now this is the PlayStation 3
version this is also a debug version so
I'm not online but I wanted to go in
here at this later time cool to show off
so I won't have online functionality but
I did kind of want to see so here we go
why are you all waiting yeah what's your
kid of it I'm glowing because I have
I'll show people my setup if they want
to see so I've got some rings on that
make me glow your Ringel a binding ring
yeah my I got bling on this limits my HP
reduction when hollow so every time you
die you go a little bit more hollow you
lose maximum health limits that ring a
blades which is for attack this is the
glow the ring of restoration and this
this gradually restores my HP and then
I'm I'm protected from physically how
many rings can you wear cuz it really
irritates me in in Skyrim that I can
wear like one ring I've got like 10
fingers why can't I wear all of these
buffs all the time it's only made for
your left thumb ring all the craftsmen
in the land can only manage one Prince
Albert I never figured out what's
actually in these wagons that makes them
go like that what it is they're some
like awful or there's like a couple
doing it in there okay yeah well given
the choice between something terrible
and awful and people joined in an
intimate Congress I know an active love
yeah yeah or maybe it's too awful things
boning
and you're made of bones and one of them
doesn't have a head and they would be
made of bones because we are we are
walking into this place that's pretty
cool
Wow awesome skeleton oh no hi frog it's
a port it's the those things it looks
like a cursed frog yeah silly he's a
petrified frog now whew
so yeah Dark Souls 2 everybody
reinventing the wheel just kidding it's
one of you like it is one of those
things so you come in here and first
time this happened to me that's kind of
frequently freaked out I think I lost it
out of the mirror oh by the way my fire
bastard sword pretty strong the family
show kept in fine art and if you have
any questions for Kevin by the way about
Dark Souls 2 please send us in a tweet
or comment on the GameSpot page or in
the twitch chat I also want to remind
folks or tell folks we're gonna show
them off in just a little bit after
Kevin's done playing this video game and
we got a bunch of copies of Dark Souls 2
to giveaway on board Xbox 360 and
PlayStation 3 incredibly awesome
versions the black armor Edition and the
collector's edition so stay tuned for
some information on how to Windows real
real soon oh yeah these are the like
steel case 1 yes they look real cool
Kevin yes Dark Souls 2 this is looking
very familiar to another game it's
called Dark Souls didn't yeah can you
just give me a sort of a brief summary
of what how you think this game is
better or worse than the previous well
there are some subtle additions that
really make a big difference
some of thats the game is a lot more
about exploration it's rather large it's
it's much bigger than Dark Souls and it
has some changes designed to get you out
there so for example if you've spawn in
an area long enough monsters will stop
respawning but not necessarily all
monsters and they don't suddenly start
doing it all at once but but they will
get phased out over time so there are
fewer monsters through here than when I
first came your not repeatedly facing
the full strength repeated enemy
deployments that you would in Dark Souls
now at first I didn't know if I was
really much
this is a julienne I just love how there
seems to be no rhyme or reason to the
creature design in this game it's just
like yeah sure
got this fragra make his eyes as big as
massive testicles on space don't tip it
their their eyeballs Danny are they not
all spheres are testicles are they well
I don't know actually I haven't played
the game have you asked for himself but
worth noting Kevin you give it a 9 out
of 10 and I think it's awesome odd
fantastic game yes so like it not not a
lesser or is it is it like so for people
who are like so into Souls games they're
gonna love it every like I don't know
like I'm back and forth somebody asked
me on Twitter how I would rank the souls
games between Demon Souls Dark Souls and
Dark Souls 2 yeah I don't know like
sometimes my feelings on that changes by
the day I think it's hard to tart to top
Dark Souls oh my god it's really dark
right there's an Dark Souls this was no
this TV is like suddenly it was not like
this before what has happened it's
almost like you've never played a game
on the show before I know I can't an
earlier to make sure and now suddenly
it's like you can do it I believe in you
cast a light spell and I've got a
question here Bob Jones 1980 yeah
vandalism those Dark Souls to integrate
with any of the save games in the first
game is there any sort of not that I'm
aware of
there could be something if there is
it's subtle I haven't noticed anything
starting in on retail from my save game
it was this dude this is uh you killed
so many of them you don't even I don't
remember the names of the enemies I
really only know the names of the bosses
really yeah I mean because the enemies
names don't really display no they just
like like oh it was that horrible robed
thing oh yeah it's a cursed frog because
it curses you well that's what I always
called them in Dark Souls was that first
frog now they're petrified frogs like I
said ahead of the smoke how long did it
take you to complete the game eighty
hours
um was that because you were was that a
review completion where you wanted to
make sure you
oh there you go you wanted death you got
death die you even touched you
oh wait darn the life of its tail and I
was down I usually go through a door
over on the right and I forgot cuz I'm
not very good at playing games and
talking at the same time honestly you
were playing Dark Souls 2 and you didn't
perish that would be sort of
disappointing yeah that would be like no
one likes a show-off Kevin come on were
you mean I do like it were you dying as
much as you were in the first game as
this stuff oh yeah I think that I died
maybe not quite as much well maybe as
much because it's bigger there are more
chance like there's more geography to
cover so maybe but I think that
individual bosses and Dark Souls were
probably a little harder than individual
bosses and Dark Souls 2 last week as
well you showed us one of the areas that
was sort of didn't look like the
quintessential of Dark Souls 1
environment where it was quite bright
and gorgeous right you also put up an
article with a bunch of screenshots from
the game just kind of looking through
it's not up yet but it will be going up
tomorrow
boilers yeah and do you think the
environments in this game are light is
there much of a difference in terms of
the scale or in terms of I think I think
there's a you know it still has the same
aesthetic clearly it's still dark souls
as it weren't so it still goes through
the same but eyes I'd say that the the
diversity is much greater there's a lot
you know you still go through forests
and and castles and things like that but
I would say in general you know you see
a lot more diversity in terms of the
geography in terms of the art style sort
of in terms of the color palette there's
there's there's a lot of stuff now I
really want to get my souls back because
I have you can do most like 18,000 souls
or something right great decent amount
of soil not bad I mean but by this far
because this character is level 141 142
easy so it's big so at this point it
doesn't really but this is where I meant
to go in before Cara bear on Twitter
asks would you say that the max HP loss
that that's is a good addition or not so
much doesn't make it unnecessary
Harger no I think that there were tweaks
to sort of how it dealt deals with
difficulty yeah
there's less of that grindy feel because
you don't have to necessarily fight
every single enemy each time you go
through an area but on the other hand
there are certain tweaks like there's it
I'll see if I can do this if I run out
of stamina I'll run out of stamina now
and then I hope stew like yeah but if
you run out of stamina and you get hit
you get knocked back your [ __ ] Egger
yeah there's a stagger there and okay
now that is something different that's
luckily I have some pyromancies so that
is actually some a source of molotovs at
it I'm a part of dr. Scott so I can I
can take care of him but that that's
pretty nasty stuff there the acid stuff
because it will degrade your your
weapons and some of the the Rings are
pretty prone to breaking so it's best to
stay out of that stuff because now stuff
breaks down but as long as it doesn't
break down fully before you rested a
bonfire it just refreshes at the bonfire
oh now this is I think they killed you
oh yeah yeah that's a pretty big thing
you want to get out of there maybe Kevin
would nasty and he'll also roll over on
me and there's a lot of physics and junk
all around me
does that does that combat system we're
all good and I feel like you're in a
real tight spot
oh you're and I'm done that's me and I'm
done oh my god good no you didn't see at
the end there's a bleeding effect so the
bleeding effects if if it succeeds it
lowers your maximum stamina for the time
but luckily it's only a temporary effect
I have a question about her Dark Souls -
Kevin because I played a bunch of Dark
Souls but I didn't get very far
and I was trying to play this like class
where I was like nimble and would roll
and like try to backstab people long but
then people who got really far in that
game seemed like they seemed to all a
lot of them be playing like pyromancers
or something
like that so like using magic with
something I didn't quite do so like when
you choose your class from the get-go
here is there like is it better to
choose a certain class or to like are
you making it harder for yourself if you
shoot if you choose the night or the you
know the bandit or whatever in the past
mages and magic we're considered sort of
like easy mode in Dark Souls and I think
that's still true to a small extent I I
do think that when you have range stuff
that can help but I've actually found
the things that I did in Dark Souls to
kind of ease my way don't work as much
here sometimes that's because there
there's certain enemies that are just
really fast they close in so fast that
you know once once you get their
attention you're you're screwed
sometimes you're in small spaces and
it's not gonna really help but there I
think archery is a lot more fun now
there are fewer chances to sort of
cheese large enemies from a distance by
just pelting them with 7,000 arrows
until they die but there are great
opportunities now to use archery you can
you can zoom in you can aim with a
crossbow which you couldn't do before so
I think that archery is now a viable
option so if it's better and viable does
that still mean it's good we are just we
actually good question here on the
screen from arrow Buster on Twitter asks
what class do you recommend to start
with in Dark Souls 2 so just starting
off maybe first time I think I am
playing as a knight and you start at
like level 13 automatically or something
like that
okay check when you when you load it up
make sure because I might be confusing
night with warrior but you do I think
that's a great place to start and keep
in mind that you know the class that you
choose only it only only really changes
like what you start as and a few
additional things like what what items
you have in equipment you have but you
can level up as you choose you can do
pretty much any
um so I didn't it's not as though I
started with pyromancy Kevin thank you
very much for coming on and showing us
Dark Souls 2 your review is up on the
slide of course everyone go read that
now